here now with more Fox News contributor
Newt Gingrich Mr Speaker thanks for
being here when you read that article
from NPR it's always weeks and months
later they begrudgingly admit things
that are just painfully obvious they
don't lay out much they say you know
other presidents did this even though
the one time they could think of is
Barack Obama going to China in 2016 and
it was almost an international insult
that they didn't have the red carpet and
the stairs prepared for him it was seen
as a backhand so what does this amongst
everything else tell you about the
trajectory of this presidency fledgling
well look I I thought his performance in
Maui
was so bad he was so clearly out of it
that frankly I think it's frightening
this is not about politics and scoring
points this is the commander-in-chief of
the most powerful military in the world
and it's clear that at least half the
time uh he's just not there I mean month
by month his cognitive collapses more
and more obvious uh the Associated Press
just reported that 77 percent of all
Americans Democrats Republicans
Independents 77 percent now believe that
Biden is too old to run for reelection I
suspect by next summer that number will
be in the 90s because once this starts
it's just going to get steadily worse
he's clearly in cognitive decline he's
clear in fact makes me wonder who's
making the real decisions at the white
house because obviously Joe Biden is not
he's not capable of it
Mr Speaker when you hear that number 77
you said it could go higher in the past
numbers like that really would have
rattled the cage of a white house and
they would have said well maybe it's
time to step away we don't seem to hear
any of that so who is based on
everything you know about Washington how
things work who is making the calls is
it is this a Jill Biden thing is this
the chief of staff thing is this a who
is it
well first of all one of the nice things
about cognitive dissonance is he may not
know the number and it may not occur to
him that it matters and he's just going
on with his life you know he's back onto
the beach he's relaxing he's doing some
bicycling uh he has a pretty decent life
and it doesn't occur to him that all
these other things are piling up in a
way that will be an absolute disaster
for the Democratic party my personal
guess is that that the driving force
behind the Biden Administration is
Barack Obama Obama is the only President
since Woodrow Wilson to stay in
Washington in Wilson's case he stayed
because he'd had a severe stroke and he
couldn't be moved so the fact that Obama
is here all the time the fact that his
staff permeates literally permeates the
bid Administration and Obama's really
really smart I mean whatever Biden's
problems are at being kind of slow and
cognitively decaying oh Obama doesn't
have any of those problems and if you
watch the administration it's much more
an Obama administration than say the Joe
Biden of 10 or 15 years ago this is a
very radical very left-wing
Administration deeply dedicated to
policies that are close to Crazy uh
their electric car policy is a disaster
as president Trump said today it's going
to destroy at least a hundred thousand
jobs and will achieve nothing in the
long run their policies across the board
going out the idea that they might
propose that Americans be limited to two
beers a week you know this is the kind
of petty Nanny State interference that
most Americans will find crazy
and of course the rumors that the masks
and the mandates could be coming back as
well those numbers will go up I think
you're right Mr speaker thank you for
breaking it down for us hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else